[Music]
on this Thursday night rapid covid test
efficacy under scrutiny the federal
government paid $2 billion for this
company's kits in this case was among
the lowest sensitivity of what we test
and new questions about the reliability
of the results a global news
exclusive deadly shooting spr spre the
Rampage at a university in Prague and
what's known about the
gunman Canada's Rising cases of
respiratory illnesses while some
hospitals are breaking the rules to
accommodate patients love them and if
you're dreaming of a white
Christmas keep on dreaming it's not
normal global national with Donna FZ
reporting tonight far ner good evening
to you thanks for joining us we are just
days away from the holidays and as covid
cases rise in many parts of this country
We Begin tonight with a global news
exclusive investigation that's raising
questions about a particular brand of
Rapid tests tests that were widely
distributed in schools hospitals and
grocery stores during the pandemic the
fromat Toronto area company called
btnx testing experts have said from the
start curbs the spread of the virus but
as Jeff simple reports this brand of
test may not have worked as well as
advertised just some pictures of of my
mom when the pandemic hit Janet Foley's
83-year-old mother Marilyn was living in
this retirement home to visit Janet was
first required to take a covid-19 rapid
test and I was an essential caregiver so
I had to be tested all the time if you
pass that test then you can go in Begin
by opening the pouch and removing the
test device the retirement home's tests
were from a Canadian company called
btnx Ottawa spent about $2 billion to
buy 400 million btnx tests in those now
familiar green
boxes but these rapid tests may not have
worked as well as advertised so it looks
like the data was manipulated for it to
be more sensitive we asked several
infectious disease specialists to review
btnx is clinical studies presented to
health Canada for approval btnx claimed
its atome rapid tests could detect
covid-19 more than 90% of the time well
above the World Health organization's
minimum threshold of 80% but the
scientists consulted by global news
found irregularities in those
results btnx is based near Toronto but
its tests are made by a company in China
Global News found btnx had removed
dozens of samples from the Test's
original clinical study without
explanation that Omission made the test
appear more sensitive
that removal of data is is a really a
violation of all research principles
btnx said it deleted the data because
the US FDA was moving towards excluding
retrospective positive samples which
btnx did as well but the FDA didn't
change its guidelines until one year
later and experts said that explanation
isn't convincing it's a complete data
set that they changed that's why it it
was strange this biomedical research
conducted a study for Spain's Health
System she recommended against buying
the test finding it was among the worst
at detecting covid-19 in asymptomatic
patients in this case was among the
lowest sensitivity of what we test in
the fall of 2020 Health Canada conducted
its own study and it found the btnx
rapid test was 100% effective at
detecting covid-19 in patients with the
very highest viral loads like the super
spreaders but in other infectious
patients the test sensitivity plummeted
far below what the company had claimed
other Studies by the British and German
governments found similar even lower
results experts say this means a
positive test result could be trusted
but not a negative one typically we
would say that's unacceptable um and
deem that the test is is not good enough
to be able to let us know that an
individual is actually infectious in
response btnx accused global news of
cherry picking data it said the Canadian
and German health ministries used poor
samples which did not accurately
represent test efficacy though
Regulators around the world were using
the same method btnx provided results
from several private studies showing
higher sensitivity levels conducted in
countries such as Pakistan and Mexico
but it declined to share the raw data
remove the swab in February 2021 Health
Canada approved the btnx test if used
properly the instructions said the tests
were more than 90% effective I think
it's outrageous that the public wasn't
as aware of the discrepancies in the
testings that had real life implications
Health Canada said it had no plans to
reassess the btnx device a spokesperson
said all authorized tests are supported
by scientific evidence demonstrating
that they consistently met standards to
provide accurate and reliable results
Janet Foley feels her trust in the rapid
tests was betrayed it's uncashable in
2022 Foley's mother Marilyn died of
covid-19 it's unclear how the virus
entered her nursing home her last
moments with her mom were spent in full
PPE holding her hand through a glove
Jeff simple Global News
Toronto we asked prime minister Justin
Trudeau about how these tests came to be
approved and if there are plans for a
review one of the things we have to
remember is during the pandemic we were
doing everything we could in uh in
unprecedented ways to get as many
different ways of keeping Canadians safe
as we possibly could there's no doubt
and obviously lots of lessons to learn
about things that worked really well
about things that we probably won't be
doing again in the next pandemic when it
comes it's not just covid-19 that's
circulating this holiday season cases of
influenza and RSV are also on the rise
putting pressure on hospitals across
this country while a spike in
respiratory viruses is normal for this
time of year Health officials fear the
situation has become far more serious as
fewer Canadians get vaccinated Heather
Yorks West
reports it's the one thing you can count
on every
December is the season for the flu it's
pretty rough right now I mean we've had
a really
explosive aggressive influenza season
the sharp takeoff and really high
hospitalization rates across the country
cases of covid the flu and RSV are
surging at virtually the same time
putting pressures on hospitals and icus
we have so many people in our Intensive
Care Unit who have really bad influenza
um in fact uh just aough sense it shows
that about 60% of our patients uh are uh
influenza complications the situation
became so crowded in healthc care
facilities across Regina this week some
hospitals were found in violation of
National Fire coats as you know this is
um you know our respiratory season where
we have quite High volumes of patients
right now getting your vaccine Regiment
of both the flu vaccine and the uh
covid-19 vaccine for the newest variants
means that uh particularly for
vulnerable people for elderly people are
going to keep folks out of hospitals are
going to reduce pressure on our hospital
system across the country the number of
people choosing to roll up their sleeve
has fallen dramatically just 15% of
Canadians got their updated covid shots
this fall and in some parts of the
country like Ontario and the north the
uptake was even lower I think we're
seeing a lot of vaccine fatigue and you
know it's really understandable it has
been a a rough uh last few years you
Alberta the number of people immunized
against the flu is currently at a 12year
low but doctors say it's not too late
the respiratory virus season typically
Peaks after the holidays but lasts until
April or May Heather URI West Global
News
Calgary in Prague now a lone gunman
killed at least 14 people and wounded 25
others in a shooting rampage in the
Heart of the City it happened at Charles
University near a busy tourist area in
Prague Old Town Police say the gunman
who was a student at the school also
died our crystal ganing is tracking the
story for us tonight
Crystal far this is the largest mass
shooting to occur in Prague in modern
history and so there is an overwhelming
sense of Devastation that's being
expressed police say the man responsible
is a 24-year-old who acted alone and
attended the
university the victims according to
police were randomly shot many in the
community didn't know what was happening
but went to the scene because of the
heavy police presence when I arrived
here the the guys from the Special
Forces told me that the attack is
happening in the in the faculty which
was for me even more stressful because
my daughter was over there police had
cleared the faculty of Arts building but
the attack unfolded at a different
location at the University they went to
the University origin looking for a
student whose father had been found dead
earlier in the day in a nearby Town
officials say the shooter who was found
dead at the scene had several guns
registered to him the Czech president
has expressed shock about the deadly
shooting the Prime Minister has called
it an inexcusable act foreign leaders
are expressing their condolences to the
families of the victims and the
community at large including Prime min
Minister Justin Trudeau as for a motive
that hasn't been made clear as of yet
however the Czech interior Minister has
said that he does not believe that this
shooting is linked to any International
acts of terrorism far crystal ganing in
London thank you Crystal there is still
no agreement on a plan to get more Aid
into Gaza as the US continues to delay a
vote at the UN Security Council several
un agencies have issued stern warnings
of an even greater humanitarian
catastrophe inside the besieged
territory with the risk of famine
increasing and the lack of Medical Care
getting even worse Jackson prco reports
in a warning the story contains
disturbing
images the situation in Gaza continues
to grow more desperate by the hour
there's not enough food water or
medicine the UN warns more than half a
million residents one in four are
starving the world help organization
says there are no longer any fully
functioning hospitals in the northern
part of Gaza they don't have Specialists
they don't have surgeons uh they don't
have power they don't have water uh they
don't have
food gaza's health authority says nearly
20,000 people have been killed during
the fighting more are at risk from
starvation and
disease behind the scenes Fierce
negotiations are underway to allow more
Aid to reach
civilians but for a third day the UN
Security Council delayed a vote on a
humanitarian resolution as the US and
Egypt debate who should inspect
materials headed into Gaza a key Demand
by
Israel the US says it still supports
Israel's military decisions we are not
dictating terms and timelines to the
Israelis uh we have certainly talked
about the importance of moving to lower
intensity operations and obviously U we
don't want them to uh to do it sooner
than they think they can do it safely
and effectively Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is not backing
down the choice I propose to Hamas is
very simple he said surrender or
die as Hamas Rockets continue to fly
over Tel Aviv families of Israeli
hostages worry time is running out with
Hamas rejecting calls for another
prisoner swap until Israel ends its
military campaign my kid I I don't want
him in a
bag I still have
hope but that hope each day that passes
by much more difficult with both sides
digging in civilians will continue to
suffer each day brings new Horrors and
little Reason for Hope Jackson prosco
Global News
Washington and Ottawa has announced new
temporary visas for people in Gaza with
extended family in Canada immigration
Minister Mark Miller says people will be
offered threeyear visas if they meet the
criteria but he does warn that the
government cannot guarantee their safe
passage there is an extensive vetting
system that is done uh on the ground and
it depends on uh the Israelis have their
say they will screen people and and and
and decide whether they leave or don't
leave we don't have any
insurances the government has focused on
getting Canadians permanent residences
their spouses and children out of Gaza
but starting on January 9th the program
is going to be extended to include
parents grandparents siblings and
grandchildren today Miller also warned
the government needs to reign in
temporary residence permits in the new
year he says the number of international
students and foreign workers is adding
pressure to Canada's housing crisis and
on the housing file the federal
government is pledging nearly half a
billion dollars from its housing
accelerator fund to build homes in
Toronto we've landed on a deal that's
going to dramatically scale up the
density it's going to lead to far more
density near Transit stations it's going
to allow people to live where the
services and economic opportunities are
in communities that already have the
infrastructure to support them the
Liberals say the money will help the
city FastTrack 12,000 new homes over the
next 3 years and more than 50,000 over
the next
decade a heartfelt plea to Ottawa coming
up what indigenous families say needs to
happen to help find their missing love
ones first Nations families in BC with
missing loved ones are calling for a
national indigenous Le search and rescue
effort the idea comes from an indigenous
man who spent his life dedicated to
finding missing people using his
traditional knowledge as a Tracker as
nuga reports one First Nation says his
culturally sensitive approach fills in
an important Gap hello two fathers my
name is Warren both with missing
children Chelsea's father Carl meet
missing the my son too for over a year
now wow offering soulless through shared
grief with his family Carl Schooner
drove 10 hours to meet Warren Holmes
whose daughter Chelsea Heron's remains
were recently found thanks to the help
of a volunteer known as Maka bear
there's a lot of people living on Shel
assistance
and and they can't provide to find their
loved one and that's where I step in
Bear had recently traveled here after
searching for months for Schooner's son
Carl Schooner Jr who went missing from
Williams Lake BC in December of
20122 went through it man but let's hope
the outcut comes better for you guys
it's one of the hardest things to go
through not
knowing your child is not knowing what
happened to him scooner hopes for a
national search and rescue effort made
up of people like Maka bear who's
dedicated his life to using traditional
knowledge as a Tracker to help where
others have failed all he asks for is
food and a place to sleep before he
returns to his search for Schooner bear
is stopping to help another family we
don't have children we don't know if
he's dead we don't know if he's alive
Curtis Raphael says his son J Preston
Raphael never returned from an outing in
February and you're hoping people buy
this and wear it to raise awareness it's
like a walking billboard the family is
appealing for any information these
First Nation families are far from alone
according to National RCMP figures in
2022 133% of all missing adults were
indigenous and 62% of all missing
indigenous adults were female but
Advocates have long warned of a lack of
awareness
and full accounting of missing
indigenous people I think that it's
really important to understand that
we're not unique in this but it is very
traumatic and it takes a lot of people
to ensure that it's done in the right
way he's gotten us through some really
rough times they say there's a clear
need for the kind of culturally
sensitive compassionate and unwavering
commitment of Maka Bear right across the
country Nara Global News saa's First
Nation sentencing day for the man who
sexually extorted Amanda Todd ahead the
decision from a Dutch
[Music]
judge a Dutch man has been given a
six-year prison sentence for harassing
and extorting British Columbia teenager
Amanda Todd before her death by Suicide
more than 11 years ago last year Aiden
cin was convicted in BC and handed a
133-year sentence by Provincial Court
today an Amsterdam Court that sentence
to 6 years the maximum allowed under
Dutch law coin will begin serving the
term after he completes an 11year
sentence that he is already
serving soccer's main governing bodies
have lost a landmark case that threatens
their hold over the sport in Europe
Europe's top court has ruled that FIFA
and UEFA which oversees European
football broke the law by blocking the
formation of a super league in 2021 and
preventing clubs from competing
competing in the proposed competition
the court said the decision doesn't
guarantee the Super League will be
[Music]
approved putting the no in snow next to
reality check for Canadians hoping for a
white
[Music]
Christmas today is the winter solstice
the official start to Winter and the
shortest day of the year and although
we're experiencing the dark associated
with it there's something missing for
many Canadians Coast to Coast the cold
as Eric senson explains the odds of
waking up to a white Christmas aren't
looking too
hot December in
[Applause]
Winnipeg wait that was last year this is
December 2023 barely a trace of snow in
a city with a 98% chance chance of a
white Christmas historically in Winnipeg
it is an issue have you seen something
like this before never in Toronto a
green Christmas in Montreal no l there
in Calgary Yeehaw no snow Winters
officially here and in BC's ski country
they have to make snow it got pretty
slushy and soupy pretty quickly which is
why we're on our way back down for
decades Northern Canada has been a shoe
in for a white Christmas only in
southern BC and green are the chances
low historically this year vast
stretches of the country where most
Canadians live a low chance of a white
Christmas sometimes I think before the
first day of winter we've already had
enough of winter in Canada and this year
it's missing an action just look at
Ottawa one of the coldest capitals in
the world where today it was easier to
swim on the canal than skate on it I
grew up here so I'm very much used to
the really big snow Banks um which I
guess we're just not really seeing
anymore not anymore in early winter it
seems a combination of long-term climate
change and the short-term warm Pacific
currents it's El Nino El Nino has been
just preventing winter from coming in
this country at least the travel should
be easier not the highway Horrors and
the airport nightmares many lived
through a year ago on the East Coast a
mix of snow with rain is in the forecast
but what snow there is in Ottawa
probably won't last the weekend for
disappointed tourists we had snow snow
and it's not normal Winnipeg still has a
chance to be normal the forecast touch
and go for the 2 cm officially required
to qualify for a white Christmas morning
I prefer a white Christmas yes but tell
the truth about the weather I'm not
going to lie and say I'm not kind of
enjoying it though A True Canadian wish
list snow and warm weather for Christmas
Eric senson Global News
Toronto too much to ask that's global
national for this Thursday I'm faran
Asser and tonight's your Canada is the
stars of place down in Montreal until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good
[Music]
night